I ran in a Chet Hanks wellheads his ran
no way no way he has all the rapper yes
and and I was at Starbucks to get my
daughter there's [ __ ] mocha
cappuccino and he was there right there
with his girlfriend yeah what does boy
he's such a nice [ __ ] is he cool and
he knew exactly who I was because he
knew cuz we talked about yeah he knew
exactly what I was a nice cool about is
the great guy yeah we never saying bad
about him I like him I said I celebrate
him yeah he's great and and but he's
just a [ __ ] he looks like an athletic
kid by the way he's an athletic strong
he looks strong it he's he's a handsome
kid sure he's great
handsome make it easy long and very very
kind very nice be nice very humble
humble cool [ __ ] how can you be
related to Tom Hanks and be meaning
exactly it's got great parents he's just
a good guy he's he's not he's not
Hollywood or anything else he's just a
good did you get within six feet of them
cuz it's Papa hat Corona he shook my
hand which I said Corona so something to
think about I wear my mask
anytime I'm close to anybody older I
when I'm inside a store I always mask up
cuz I don't want to I don't want to [ __ ]
with anybody older who's afraid old
people are afraid they should be yeah
they should be and I guess we do have a
real surge we don't we don't know
surgeon cases Sunday was the lowest
death rate we've ever had that's
important i I don't know that's very
important yes
all right every we can freak out do what
you want to do but that's what I want
yes I wait we've ever had a chat sighs I
like his eyes
I like those tight the skin is tight
that's a tight lid Oh give me that I'm
all about tight sometimes his dad's lids
aren't bad either
his dad probably had my surgery yeah or
he's probably more secure than me
yeah here's the thing no I'd rather have
your neck than Tom's
yeah I got a good ah don't say it get on
my neck dude the Earthworm Jim forehead
though hey earthworm jim earthworm jim
belly belly on your forehead son I did
everything you're not supposed to don't
rub your eyes constantly rubbing them
don't get in the shower come on let's go
oh that's [ __ ] off you till you can't
shower I mean [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off a gangster Brian dead seriously
text me his the end of his text put [ __ ]
it ride or die
and I went listen he's time I some debts
here something listen don't ever say
Reiner die again or don't ever take my
ride or die every guy you put okay okay
okay so aggressive hey you know jet
Hank's too much yeah dude I run with a
serious crew know I'm a fan of his good
guy [ __ ] very pleasantly did you you
very pretty girlfriend
Howie I bad a sister a sitter dad that's
force
yeah hump yeah you'll kind of chick in a
beautiful beautiful black woman oh cord
you liked the chocolate
yeah he's she's she's she's like she's
beautiful so you know everybody like
listen he's a good-looking dude to what
you really good-looking dude what uh
handsome kid I'll tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]